all right so Dora is plucked out of the
jungle placed in high school
and she's really a fish out of water
but when was the last time you felt like
you were a fish out of water right now
right now I feel like there's no water
in Hollywood in general just like I
didn't look like the cutesy little
blonde eyed blonde blue-eyed girls that
I would go into auditions with and then
you know just finally I think I found my
place kind of with with this cast and
with all the people I've met that behind
the scenes that are really wonderful and
I think Holly was becoming more diverse
I mean maybe because it's just a trend
but I hope that with movies like this
it'll be solidified yeah yeah for sure
well and you're right I think slowly but
surely we still we still I think that
you're right about that this is your
first major role yeah so it's sinking in
now it's here what do you think you're
gonna remember and take away from this
the most oh man this has been such a
this whole thing this whole press for
like the movie everything is such an
adventure I mean I got to see so much of
the world and meet so many amazing
people probably that just just getting
to see so many different things and it's
amazing I feel so lucky yeah it kind of
feels like a weird dream yeah like the
things that happened to me I meant Danny
Trejo yesterday no I asked to put him on
my back I know
he said he's okay up to me to came up
and spoke to me that was really really
weird how about those to the voices of
like this is why Danny Trejo and Benicio
del Toro I didn't get Joyce smart man
you I loved what he did with the sunrise
and then with boots you wouldn't expect
the voice of elo but it was James
bobbins idea the director to make the
voice so low and shocking yeah and
iconic and I think everyone in the
theater my favorite is hearing the
reactions everyone they're like whoa
if I'm being honest I did walk into the
movie yesterday thinking I don't know if
this is the movie for me and I came out
like Holy Smoke I know this was so cute
I know you were so give you your props
like and both of you together I'm like
okay two stars two stars being born
right it's a great dynamic yeah you know
he's so cool and naturally and
effortlessly and I'm just like let's go
at waist energetic and so we were like
this in real life so no she has such a
bright light in real life and it really
shine don't imagine me on coffee it's
bad that is will you quit now I kind of
you had some more resurfacing my
caffeine mean I was gonna say so why'd
you decide I've never had a cup of
coffee I can't do it I can't do it I'm
too sensitive
I got a sensitive stomach yeah like
don't put dairy in front of me like you
know for me it's the caffeine like I
feel like I feel like I just did crack
[Laughter]
this movie is not really about finding
yourself we hear that a lot
it's about paper Jeff he's like what did
I do oh it's about being yourself hmm so
when's the last time you had to remind
yourself like just just do you just be
you probably during press days yes
because it's a lot of pressure you know
if you think about it too much yeah um
but specifically in my music I'm working
on my music so um I just really really
have to constantly remind myself to be
myself and not fall for like what's
popular now because no one's ever done
anything important chasing the trend I
was wondering if you really like one to
sing cuz you got a great voice coming
out this she says album coming out I'm
so great it's well it's coming out
definitely before the end of the year
like it's you know yeah she has a record
what's the vibe what's the vibe of the
album it's what bilingual is bilingual
and
like its pop I guess you could say Papa
like a little bit more alternative you
know I gotta be a little bit more pop
for the first time it comes out I'm
gonna okay but to all to your defense
like pop is some of the hardest music to
write like to make a good pop song and
she writes her own music to make a good
pop song is so difficult and people get
I feel like people just kind of brush it
off but pop is like the to make a catchy
pop song is not easy
yeah yeah it's not to make a Bop I guess
you're now just trying to find my sound
and whatnot and I'm excited I'm really
it's gonna be my best most favorite
creative outlet that I've ever not and
you write your own music yeah yeah I
mean I have an executive producer and a
producer because I don't I can produce
music but I yeah I write my melodies
atleast so we came up with a list of
questions that we want to ask you just
kind of like so everybody can get to
know Isabella and Jeff okay
first off you both have a Mark Wahlberg
tie which is cool what's your favorite
Mark Wahlberg memory um do you only go
first
I have one I feel like you have just as
much as me if not more there was one
time where I brought a friend to set and
he was a guy and Mark had never been
fond of me and guys everything right in
the same room and so he went to go get
lunch one time we were my trailer and
Morgan eyes trailer to face each other
and I guess he came back and he was
mortified and I'm like what happened
he's like well I walked out of a trailer
made direct eye contact with Mark I
waved and he just stared at me he just
gave me like the most like the coldest
air I've ever felt and like he hates me
scary guy I was like well you're a guy
walking out of my tree didn't really put
it on people like with the looks like
when it comes to like him being
protective of the ladies in his life no
I know my cousin his his daughter has
like a boyfriend and he hates it I've
seen better and it's just like I'm just
like stared being around them that's it
yeah I know about you I think mines is
just like whenever I get to travel with
him it's really fun we travel places
together sometimes and recently we went
to Vegas which I had never been to Vegas
before and it was you're old enough yeah
it was interesting cool
first Vegas experts Vegas do tell you
know okay something about you guys that
most people wouldn't realize or that
they'd actually just be surprised to to
learn about oh I have one you go I was
born with two extra fingers oh you had
sick nobody believes me you see the mark
right no my cousin the same the marker
here my mom had it too yeah its its
genetic
I've already he's been to her yeah um
something about me that no one would
know why it's he knows you better than
you know yourself
um I can burp like a lot yes like not on
command but it's like her burps are
insane oh so what's a 10 they'd like
come you'll know you had a 10 I figured
that was always eating crafty okay
what's your TV guilty pleasure love
island yes we are watching love island
last night that was my first time seeing
it u.s. our UK u.s. yeah because it's
the only one that'll play on these
things but mine's is like any like
surgery show like I love watching
surgery thank you a dr. pimple popper
dr. Pym too big for me those pimples are
a little too big and they bleed it means
I really feel gross
but the
little cute little blackheads perfect so
good
every time I know we're like watching
like a tummy tuck to is really just like
yeah will you see that like every change
it's just so it's amazing that we can
get cut people up and not change my head
at Wendy Williams moment you know she's
like okay your current movie star crush
Margot Robbie this girl
Isabella moaning oh it's weird because
you're my cousin's she's real cute she's
adorable and that she's about to be
indoors I heard yeah I haven't seen it
yet but I've heard good things
oh that's really cute your dream co-star
outside this group of actors that you
did this movie with my life or did this
what you can bring them back okay Philip
Seymour Hoffman icon legend um
I guess right off the bat Natalie
Portman mm-hmm yeah I just I just want
to her honestly like not even like I
would love to be in a movie with her but
just I'd talk to her yeah she's really
good she really is okay the best advice
you've ever received about working in
Hollywood and who was it from
I know mine do it stomp don't Lisa grind
don't lose her guy and that was from
Uncle Mark don't lose your hustle don't
get comfortable yeah um well so it
wasn't necessarily advice but like
Benicio del Toro made a bet with me that
I was gonna win an Oscar and if I don't
win an Oscar he owes me $5 and if $5
yeah girl you should have Briony you $4
he got money against my
well I'll take that bet
hey I thought that was the coolest thing
that ever happened to me in my career
like he's awesome that's really cool I
had such a good time with you guys thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]